krieger d'eau carvajal chef du service
des urgences pédiatriques à l'hôpital
trousseau à paris
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ont longtemps à peu près tout et
son contraire concernant la
contamination des enfants qu'est ce que
ça révèle selon vous la quiétude
importante qui existait actuellement sur
cette maladie là qui est une maladie
grave chez l'adulte et surtout ça la
personne de plus âgés mais concernant
l'enfant depuis le début les premiers
papiers puis j'ai parlé chinois sur 72
mille cas il y avait quelqu'un en france
simplement il n'y avait aucun décès il y
avait moins d'un pour cent des enfants
de moins d'un an
donc nous on s'était dit mathias et les
chinois ensuite les italiens ont pilé la
même chose
l'espagne des états unis et puis nous on
fait encore faire la même chose à des
enfants sont très peu touché par cette
maladie
et lorsqu'il le samba ils sont avec des
formes extrêmement du nom banal par
rapport à la gravité chez l'adulte
très honnêtement ça se traduit par quoi
qu'est ce que vous voyez dans votre
service
est-ce que vous avez soigner des enfants
qui auraient été attendu coronavirus à
quelles sont leurs symptômes quelle est
la gravité de la maladie chez eux
elle est très banal tous les enfants que
nous avons eues on a un peu moins de
vingt passion dont tout doux tout la
période à notre hôpital c'est un hôpital
universitaire habituellement nous avons
centre compte cinq mille passages par an
et sur la période dé surveillance pas
nous avons recensé un peu moins de 20
cas ils ont tous bien évolué il y avait
surtout des tout petits est ce que ce
qui est clair et que la contamination
ait dans le sens descendant c'est à dire
quasiment la totalité des passions que
nous avons eu ce sont des contaminations
dans lesquelles il y avait un contact
parental familiale qu'est ce que vous
vous avez pensé de cette qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette maladie de kawasaki
dont on entend le plus en plus parler
ces derniers jours une quinzaine de cas
d'enfants seraient recensés dans le pays
car garé ce que vous portez sur ce
dernier dossier
oui en fait effectivement le set locaux
vides nous apprend tous les jours
quelque chose et plus le temps passe
pour en apprendre des choses qui sont un
peu inhabituelles et exceptionnelles
concernant l'enfant effectivement des
puits durant trois semaines on a
commencé à constater des cas inhabituels
de maladie de kawasaki ou des maladies
ressemblant à la maladie de kawasaki
alors que ce n'était pas la fréquence
habituelle des éléments importants de
cette maladie par rapport à ce que nous
connaissons était due en âge souvent
supérieure à celle que nous avons
constatée habituellement il est pédiatre
à connaissent très bien à la maladie de
kawasaki n est pas quelque chose de
nouveau alors peut-être à l'ordre du
retour à l'école des enfants il est donc
prévu le 11 mai ce que selon vous
aujourd'hui les sons risque
ben je pense que la vie sans risque
n'existait pas mais il y a le niveau de
risque
ce que nous on sait au niveau des
pédiatres et que avec les données que je
vous ai donné
et puis les études et ils sont très
claires les contaminations qui ont été
observés chez des enfants dans au moins
90% voire plus de situations où on s'est
penché sur les cas ça c'était des
contaminations intrafamiliales et avec
souvent les parents c'est à dire que les
enfants sont contaminés par les parents
à 8,6 à risque de contamination et dans
les foyers et il ya très peu de
contamination entre les enfants savaient
pas dire que nul mais la contamination
entre les enfants et plus faibles et
puis combien même ils le sont encore une
fois la maladie est très moment pour
l'immense majorité des cas assez banal
certains cas ont nécessité des soins en
plus aiguë notamment dans le six cadets
maladie de kawasaki il ya eu des des
besoins d'assistance circulatoire mais à
ma connaissance la vente n des cas qui
ont été identifiés comme étant
probablement lié au co vide en
ile-de-france faisons tous bien évolué
et à ceyrat
bon c'est pas des séjours prolongés en
animation c'est une évolution qui sont
assez courtes
quelles mesures doivent être prises
d'ici au 11 mai pour accueillir au mieux
en toute sécurité les enfants l'école
moi je pense qu'une des mesures
importantes épidémies logique et là j'ai
actuellement toutes les études en
dessous des 15 ans montre bien que le
risque est extrêmement faible
à partir de 15 ans 18 ans 19 ans là le
risque en mode discrètement mais il
n'est pas du tout comparable à celle de
l'adulte donc ça veut dire qu'en fait
pour les plus jeunes enfants bien sûr
qu'on doit on doit avoir des des
distanciation social au niveau de
d'école et puis peut-être diminuer au
maximum les contacts mais c'est quelque
chose qui est impossible
gd chez les jeunes enfants je vois pas
comment ce qu'on maternelle ou en
primaire on pourra éviter que les
enfants c'est touche entre eux le je
dirais qu'on fait il ya l'aspect des
risques pour les enfants et leur
contamination entre qui à mon sens est
très très faible et par contre un autre
élément c'est la contamination aux
adultes et elle l'a encore une fois les
enfants sont très peu contaminés par
rapports aux adultes restés d'éléments
des contaminants entre des adultes donc
effectivement les mesures d
distanciation sociale à l'intérieur de
l'école entre des adultes doivent être
les mêmes que l'on préconise depuis
certain temps c'est à des situations
sociales et masques
or le maximum possible merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions rijkaard aucun bajal je
rappelle que vous êtes chef du service
des urgences pédiatriques de l'hôpital
trousseau à paris